obviously we knew that he was in some
Thomas's hospital it was all over the
news and that he had been gone into ICU
but our daughters very professional so
we don't um ask things or or she doesn't
spill things so it really wasn't until
he was out of intensive care that she
actually told us well she said she had
just had a most surreal time in her life
something she will never forget and that
she had been taking care of course it
makes us feel exceptionally proud
obviously but she has told us these
things over the years and it doesn't
matter what patient she's looking after
this is what she does and I just find it
incredible that she any nurses can do
this for 12 hours sit and watch a
patient and twiddle away with all the
different knobs and things they do to
keep their patients alive it's
absolutely amazing I think over the
years she has always told us that her
job is one-on-one nursing with very
critically ill people and that means
she's there all the time for the 12
hours so once we had heard the virus
Johnson had gone and to intensive care
it was obvious that at some stage Ginny
would possibly run into him and giving
him the same level of care that she
would have given anybody else the week
before or next week and we're really
proud of her Ginny is a girl that loves
life absolutely loves life and you'll
find that an awful lot of nurses and
medical people love life they work hard
and they play hard and she just loves
her life in London she originally took
on nursing because she wanted to travel
and she knew that nursing was a good
occupation to have she really wanted to
go to university because all her friends
were going to university and she didn't
really know what she wanted to study um
she had a grandmother who was a nurse
very dedicated and I think it was I that
suggested it - why don't you try nursing
so she
and she excelled well I think Jenny was
home last month and and she assured us
that the national health were prepared
and ready and trained for the covert 19
outbreak that was coming their way
and she just assured us not to be
worried because we trained for this and
if anything she was actually looking
forward if he could if that's the right
word to being involved and so we have to
take her word for it we see the nurses
and the doctors on the TV programs
completely robed up and and that's what
she's like all day long and we've seen
the photos of her when she takes all
that gear off and it looks as
distressing as a lot of other nurses
show when they're on TV with that once
they've taken their protective gear off
but she's reasonably confident that she
can keep herself safe so we just have to
trust them she's more worried about us
keeping ourselves safe back here and in
said I think she will be exhausted and I
think she will probably be overwhelmed
and you want to go home and have a good
sleep